what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay so I have the con crud so I sound a
little under the weather so you guys are
going to have to bear with me but this
video I think is going to be huge for
Green Lantern fans and in fact when this
video came out I ask how much story in
the whole off so I could get what views
I could when I could because whenever he
uploads Green Lantern stuff it doesn't
matter what it is everybody watches it
and sounds like okay let me get what
views I can and then you could have
loved your a later video and it'll go
absolutely nuts but what this does is
this gives us basically the origin of
both soon and this is a story that's
been long and telling right and because
close we guys she never read Jeff jobs
Green Lantern with both whom he was just
dare one day like it was just suddenly
he's here he's running amok and there
was a little bit of expedition that was
given and Jeff Jones offered a little
bit in the way of say well both to him
was the first in the lantern he taught
the Guardians how to tap into the
emotional spectrum you know he went
crazy with power and that was it that
was really all we got you know he was
contained and the Green Lantern's came
along and the other Lantern cores and so
on and so forth but there wasn't this
great big huge like origin story that
was given and so what this does is this
really harkens back to really the end of
volthoom within the Jeff jobs continuity
where he was defeated by
necron now necrons an interesting
scenario when it comes to to DC Comics
because Nakata is actually one of the
few instances in DC Comics where Jeff
Jobs did not create something new
instead what he did is he would he
reworked it there we go necron was a guy
who debut back in 1981 with like I want
to say it was tales of the Green Lantern
course and all that really was was an
attempt by DC to basically beef up the
Lantern metho so they remember doctor in
the 1960s 70s 80s they could not get
people to care about Hal Jordan there
were instances where stories would do
well especially when it was Green
Lantern Green Arrow but it was only
really because of the fact that that you
know the stories of how to order being
told in tandem was the stories of you
know Green Arrow Oliver Queen with the
two of them teaming up that made the
comic interesting but as soon as Green
Arrow got his own publication the house
orden stories started tanking again but
the net crown was originally introduced
as like this kind of like avatar of
death like character where it was like
you know anybody who comes across them
it's basically like they're fighting
death
every was interesting for what it was
but when Jeff Jones came back during the
Green Lantern mythos and said we're
basically inventing the emotional
spectrum
he took the concept of necron threw him
into the emotional spectrum and said no
no he's not just some weird entity that
kind of stands between the realm of life
and death where people who die pass on
to the next realm instead it was like
necron is this avatar of the Black
Lantern core he's the avatar of the
death Lantern core basically and
provided the electron with a whole new
host of powers resurrecting the dead
making him part of his behalf so on and
so forth it was really part of like the
whole blackest night story I think it
was it was cool to see this huge revamp
but the idea here was that volson was
basically defeated by necrons so because
of the fact that Necron is essentially
deaf so to experienced the touch of
Necron you know it's to basically
experience death itself and so while
he's talking to necron anyway ah the
idea is it kind of harkens back now keep
in mind with regards to this particular
segment this is basically him just sort
of giving us his origin and what he
tells us is that on earth 15 you know a
world real wildly different from the
main DC Universe that volthoom and his
mother were very much explores and the
cool thing about this is that Sam
Humphreys because the Green Lantern is
designed to be a jumping-off point Sam
Humphreys goes with familiarity remember
Green Lantern's is for the new Green
Lantern readers if you've never read
Jeff John three legend run Green Lantern
is by Sam Humphreys it's a story for you
it's the one that will get you into all
this and so it's it's it's appropriate
that this origin story takes up here
but the idea is the same Humphreys goes
with familiarity you know Superman's
origin story is timeless you know
Superman's origin story will always be
the definitive origin what Sam Humphreys
does is draw on this origin by depicting
to us a world that's basically dying
that's experiencing its own Cataclysm
both Sam and his mother were scientists
but in their their process of making
different things one day it done is a it
constructed something called for the
travel Lantern and what the travel
answer did was basically allow people to
traverse the landscape to move between
universes Letourneau lancer was very
much a part of the other Green Lantern
mythos with regards to volt soon but
it's cool to see how he got from 20a to
point B and so when he was a instruction
to do was basically go on a mission into
the multiverse by his mother and find a
way to save the world and that's the
cool thing here initially he just jumps
from one reality to the next but the
cool thing is that Sam Humphries and
just say hey this happened and then that
have
that happened he very much goes into the
mind of Volta that's why this works is
because of all to himself traveling to
the multiverse time and space starts to
lose its meaning because keep in mind
one of the ways in which comic book
publishers value DC Marvel one of the
ways in which they basically keep things
whole they keep things structured and
they keep things interesting in society
that just because 24 hours is how long
it takes for a data path in the main
Marvel or the main diet or the main DC
universe doesn't mean it's the same way
in another universe in another universe
the earth might orbit the Sun at a
faster rate which means that it takes
less time for a data past maybe it
orbits the Sun at a slower rate which
means it takes more time for a data path
as that was cool how these how easy Oh
different realities coincide with one
another but the issue is that as both
doom makes his way through the
multiverse he comes across dying worlds
he comes across worlds that are wildly
different than his own but none of them
have the kind of scientist that he's
looking for that will allow him to
basically complete his task teaching
them to tie in August's happened to the
emotional spectrum and then using their
knowledge of the emotional spectrum to
help him fulfill a school because rubber
it was both human his mother that first
learned how to harness the emotional
spectrum we don't know how they did we
just know that they did but the cool
thing is that it also is Sam Humphreys
tying into questions that we have with
regards to the Green Lantern mythos the
first of these comes with regards to
earth 17 now earth 17 is actually part
of Grant Morrison's Multiversity
released it was revamped during grant
Moore's is also a Multiversity and all
we knew is that there was some kind of
Cataclysm that it basically laid waste
to everything their life had been set
back by middle thousands of years it was
very medieval in terms of how it
functions but the arrival of a loom
coincides with the desire of humanity
actually existed at that time to
basically restore earth back to the way
it was to grow plant lactam and things
like that and he was able to help them
achieve that goal which again kind of
caps into this emotional spectrum
concept of how it is that Alan Scott
uses the Green Lantern ring at the same
time he travelled at earth 47 earth 47
is a Multiversity concept by Grant
Morrison where it's basically a world
where the 60s never ended pretty much
what it is but that's basically how that
world is but it's cool because what he
does is he teaches them how it happened
the emotional spectrum but they're not
scientists they use the emotional
spectrum to make music now for those of
you guys who read forever evil and you
were wondering the power ring from Earth
3 how does volthoom and
powering tie into volthoom in the PAL
Jordan and the Green Lantern mythos the
answer is given to us here what had
happened is somewhere along the line
voloom had traveled to earth 3 and he
had found a wizard that had basically
taken a piece of its soul and created a
power ring for that purpose the issue
was that the two of them basically had a
falling-out in terms of how the wizard
wanted to use the ring now simply like
going through what we know with regards
to earth 3 the ring that was created by
this wizard presumably passed on to Hal
Jordan of Earth 3 who was a coward who
adopted the mantle of power ring the
result was that when forever evil happen
and the occupants of earth 3 invaded the
main DC Universe it ultimately led to
power league I guess the ring of
volthoom as it existed passing on to
Jessica Cruz and so Jessica Cruz it's
quite literally wielding a ring that has
a fraction of the soul of the volthoom
that we're familiar with inside the ring
itself and the reason why this is such a
huge deal is because this was never
answered for years and years and years
vo DC never answered this question we
just had the ring of voloom and that we
had the villain voloom and we had no
idea how one tied to the other this
answers that question so if a lot of you
guys who were just we've just been
wondering how do they reconcile with
each other that's where this comes from
now from here we basically switch over
to earth you or earth prime that's
really what it is the new 52 earth is
essentially what's going on here and
this is one bull Foom first arrives and
encounters the guardians of the universe
now some of that I want to point out
here is that the arrival of voloom
basically takes place after chroma and
so what that means is that where Corona
was one of the members of the guardians
who had wanted to look back to the
origin of all things and basically
initiated the events that would lead
into crisis on the first this goes after
all that and so instead with a guardian
to basically abandon their other home
planet where they were trying to go
through and shed their emotion in order
to become basically individuals who
could observe the future of the universe
without being tied into it emotionally
the arrival of voloom granted them that
of course because of the fact that they
were scientists because they were so
intelligent from both dooms perspective
he saw them as people who can help who
could help him achieve his goal of
acquiring the power necessary to save
his planet the way this power came
through was by the guardians of the
universe
casting aside their emotion and pouring
it in side of the battery Lantern itself
and the result was that it basically
allowed the guardians to go forward
without emotion but what this did
that also allowed them to begin the
process of learning how to tap into the
emotional spectrum and so the result was
that where their efforts formed a
singular ring that was wildly powerful
it could use all of the emotional
spectrum in and of itself this led into
both soon because welding was basically
the first Lantern voloom was the first
individual to be able to harness the
entirety of the emotional spectrum as to
what this tells us is that where
previously it may have been thought the
volsung was a guy who could just tap
into the emotional spectrum in and of
itself that he was basically a conduit
forward instead what had happened was a
ring was created that allowed him to
achieve that goal and so the result was
that he went forward basically operating
as the guardians agent in order to
ensure that a lawful state existed in
the universe itself that things wouldn't
go awry the problem is that well soon
became drunk with power
and so because well soon became drunk
with power he began to become immersed
in the emotional spectrum you know will
rage death life so on someone it got to
a point where his mind began to fracture
he began to literally go insane now what
one thing tells us is that try as he
might he was unable to hide it from the
Guardians the time eventually came where
his wrath his insanity began to get the
best of them and when the Guardians
realized what it was he was doing the
guardians used their ability to tap into
the emotional spectrum and created the
first set of the first seven Green
Lantern's now I talked a comic story
about this because as far as I knew the
chronology of the Lantern mythos was
that vo you had both - who showed up he
taught the Guardians how'd it happen -
the emotional spectrum both doom went
crazy the Guardians basically imprisoned
him the result was that they created the
Manhunters the Manhunters went crazy
so then they use the emotional spectrum
to create the Green Lantern Court that
was my understanding of the mythos what
seems to be happening here is basically
a retcon Sam Humphreys is coming back
and saying that were previously we
thought it went in the order of you know
bull Foom and the Manhunters and in the
Green Lantern court instead it was
masoom and between the time where we'll
soon came to power and the creation of
the Manhunters that the Guardians
created seven lanterns using the
emotional structure where I guess using
willpower from the emotional spectrum
and the result was that the seven
lanterns of the seventh the first seven
were able to take down both tomb and
they were able to basically lead him to
being imprisoned the issue with this is
that we're hoping was in prison for
however many billion years on his mind
he was constantly thinking about the
idea that his world was a
being destroyed his world was
effectively gone and so the result of
this was that he began to sort of lose
his mind he began to go crazy began to
become obsessed with the idea of revenge
and so what this does is this bookend to
his emergence with regards to the the
Geoff Johns Green Lantern mythos and so
this is where this basically goes into
when he was first released when he first
broke out when he first encountered Hal
Jordan the rest of the Green Lantern's
you know the wrath of the first Lantern
story arc and all that and so it was
really really cool the way to sort of
fit in bits and pieces of this you could
really kind of like take this comic and
you could chop it up into sections and
you could inject each one of these
sections into a part of the Geoff Johns
Green Lantern mythos and make it a more
cohesive story that's a great thing
about origins those origins come back
and they kind of provide a much bigger
picture here the issue is that what this
does is it kind of transitions back
around to the modern day right now to
keep them on with what's happening at
this moment this is again both soon
speaking with Necron desiring to be
killed now we're Necron it basically you
know eliminated voloom you know in the
original Geoff Johns Green Lantern
Memphis his conversation with necron
here is a desire for death because it's
basically falsely saying I've been alive
for billions of years I'm effectively
one with the emotional spectrum the
weight of the spectrum is it's such a
degree that I don't want to live anymore
necrons responses you have no idea where
you are I couldn't kill you even if I
wanted to because you are the emotional
spectrum you're a living embodiment of
the emotional spectrum if I were to
destroy you you would only come back you
would you would come back in some form
or fashion
and that's what's happening here that
crimes basically saying that the
emotional spectrum is pulling you back
to life is basically reconstituting you
it's giving you a new form again and so
because of this it's effectively necron
saying volton can never die voloom is an
intrinsic part of existence now this is
really kind of interesting because DC
does not do this the same way that
Marvel this right like Marvel will sit
down a mob will say Marv will say okay
there's the Phoenix force there's only
one Phoenix force and all the multiverse
but the Phoenix force will have an
avatar in each universe and the main
Marvel Universe is team gray and another
universe is quit inquire in another
universe it could be the villain
apocalypse or it could be Wolverine or
something like that
but the Phoenix will have avatars all
around the multiverse but there's only
one Phoenix force with regards to what
goes on in this mythos this Green
Lantern landscape
M Humphries is basically doing the same
thing where he's saying that no matter
what universe exists there's only one
real bull food there's only one actual
balloon being the character will assume
is a harbinger of the emotional spectrum
the two are part and parcel to each
other and so as long as the emotional
spectrum exist both soon will never die
it will require the emotional spectrum
to be blinked out of existence
well the caveat to this is the emotional
spectrum is effectively powered by the
emotions of existence and so long as the
multiverse exists the emotional spectrum
will exist and so in order for the
emotional spectrum to stop existing
everything in existence would have to go
away we said a lot of existence there
everything that that will really I mean
that exists we'll just have to vanish
and so again it's basically Sam
Humphreys saying both soon will never
die and so what happened is with all
doom you know sitting down to realizing
that he's cursed to existence his idea
he also begins to realize that Randy had
basically created a phantom Lantern a
phantom ring the phantom ring of course
being the object that anyone can wheel
because keep in mind in order for
someone to be able to pick up like or in
order to be able to use a Green Lantern
ring or a Blue Lantern ring or Red
Lantern ring they have to be able to
utilize hope or will or rage whatever
the case may be they have to be able to
utilize those things but with regards to
the phantom ring anybody can pick it up
it doesn't have to choose you you can
just be walking along see is putting on
a desk somewhere pick it up and suddenly
you can tap into the entirety of the
emotional spectrum but the reason why
this matters so much for well Tim is not
only because of the fact that the
phantom ring doesn't have any kind of
like a safety mechanism but because of
the fact that the the Phantom ring will
allow him to mainline the entirety of
the emotional spectrum it sorts like him
getting his own ring back
it's him getting a ring that will
allowing him to utilize the full extent
of his powers and that's really where
this end it's really just the idea that
volthoom began chasing after Remmy and
so what this did is this wrap back
around to the start of the phantom
Lantern story where basically explains
why it is that whole zoom appeared on
earth with regards to the arrival of
Remmy and the phantom ring itself and so
this is really it to be honest is really
more like a prelude to the phantom
Lantern story arc moreso than anything
else and so I'm not really sure why it
came out now it would make more sense to
have it come out beforehand but I think
the other reason why this happens
because Sam hunter is was kind of going
for shock value when we found out that
volthoom had basically retorted that
really seemed to be the reason why
but with that being said guys is there
any questions feel free to post it down
in the comment section I really hope
this makes simply great let your Mythos
for you I really hope it kind of pulls
things together but if you find yourself
a bit confused go ahead and fill a
question down in the comment section I
or a little bit more my channel will
probably will try to answer it as best
we can but if you're new here to come
and explain make sure you hit the sub
button to become part of the rod Court
you enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
all later please
[Music]